[Música]
hora de hablar de medio ambiente en
france 24 yo soy maría clara calle hoy
hablaremos de los impactos ambientales
que ha tenido el volcán cumbre vieja en
la isla española de la palma y también
vamos a explicar algunos de los
proyectos verdes con los que la unión
europea apoya a américa latina'
comencemos en europa desde que el volcán
cumbre vieja entró en erupción el 19 de
septiembre ha arrojado más de 80
millones de metros cúbicos de lava esto
tiene consecuencias ambientales como la
cantidad de dióxido de azufre que libera
con la erupción del volcán pinatubo en
filipinas hace 30 años se probó que el
dióxido de azufre disminuyó la
temperatura en 0,5 grados celsius pero
es poco probable que cumbre vieja haga
lo mismo pues las 250 mil toneladas de
este gas que ha emitido están lejos de
igualar las 20 millones de toneladas del
volcán filipino lo que sí ha ocurrido es
que el dióxido de azufre de la isla
canaria llegó hasta el norte de áfrica e
incluso al caribe a países como puerto
rico y república dominicana
estas imágenes del servicio copernicus
de la agencia espacial europea muestran
el recorrido esto ocurre porque el
dióxido de azufre se transporta por las
mismas corrientes de aire que hacen que
el polvo del sahara llegue hasta el
amazonas cuando este gas se concentra en
altas cantidades y por largo tiempo
puede tener impactos en las personas y
en la biodiversidad y es que puede
afectar los pulmones de los seres
humanos y causar irritación en los ojos
también puede dañar la vegetación
degradar la clorofila y reducir la
fotosíntesis lo que conllevaría a una
pérdida de especies sin embargo los
volcanes no son los que producen más
dióxido de azufre
la combustión del petróleo y otros
carburantes fósiles es lo que más genera
este tipo de gas en todo el mundo
y ahora volvamos al volcán cumbre vieja
porque desde que toco el mar el 28 de
septiembre ha tenido múltiples
consecuencias por ejemplo el magma
recorrió 6 kilómetros hasta que entró al
mar por la playa de los guirres el
choque de temperaturas entre los 1100
grados centígrados del magma y los 20
del agua hizo que las rocas del volcán
se endurecieran esto significa que el
territorio de la isla se expandió más de
32 hectáreas sobre el mar a esto se le
llama delta de lava o fajana como lo ven
en las imágenes los expertos creen que
en un futuro nuevas especies marinas
podrán vivir alrededor pero las noticias
pueden no ser tan buenas por ahora los
químicos de la lava hacen que el agua
del mar sea más ácida con más dióxido de
carbono y menos oxígeno una combinación
mortal para muchas especies sin embargo
la ong ben magec-ecologistas en acción
afirmó que parte de la fauna marina se
fue de las costas de la palma antes de
que llegara a la lava probablemente por
los cambios de la temperatura que ya se
sentían las consecuencias exactas de
este delta del agua solo se sabrán
después de que los científicos terminen
sus estudios el instituto español de
oceanografía pasó 10 días monitoreando
desde un buque lo que ocurría con la
fajana y están analizando 500 litros de
agua que recolectar la ciencia ya tiene
indicios de que puede pasar en estos
casos el mismo instituto estudio los
impactos de la erupción submarina del
volcán el hierro también en las islas
canarias y que ocurrió en 2011
demostraron que el magma perturbó el
ecosistema marino y redujo la
biodiversidad aunque no todas las
noticias son malas también aparecieron
nuevas especies que suelen vivir en
aguas calientes y el plancton se
multiplicó vamos ahora a américa latina'
y hablar de los proyectos que respaldan
la unión europea en el continente y es
que con el pacto verde europeo el bloque
aspira a lograr la neutralidad de
carbono en 2015 en su lucha están
buscando países aliados y en el
continente ya son 18 ellos trabajan en
la deforestación en la reducción de
carbono y en la movilidad sostenible
entre otros proyectos uno de sus
objetivos es lograr un comercio que
respete el medio
y nosotros financiamos proyectos en
latinoamérica porque primeramente
tenemos esa idea de alguna diplomacia
climática que es un tema global cosa que
vemos calculadora y apoyar esto con com
proyectos pero además hay temas
importantes tenemos ese acuerdo de
comercio
en mis comienzos los europeos siempre
hicieron por supuesto si hacemos
comercio que es de los aspectos sociales
y medioambiente bien nuestros europeos
que importan productos de latinoamérica
y quiero enseñar que aquí el medio
ambiente está lentamente de giros en sus
puestos que hacemos realmente apoyando
esto fue lo que nos dijo el agregado en
la feria internacional de medio ambiente
que se realizó en bogotá la unión
europea cofinancia proyectos de los
gobiernos y luego paga por resultados
otra vía es financiar directamente las
ideas de la sociedad civil todo esto
hace parte del plan financiero de 2021 a
las delegaciones de la unión europea
trabajan con el gobierno con la sociedad
civil con el sector privado durante
aproximadamente dos años preparando
justamente la programación de estos
siete años cada país tiene unos desafíos
concretos y normalmente nos fijamos un
número de prioridades limitados máximo 3
porque no podemos estar en todos los
sectores y de hecho trabajamos también
un mano a mano con los estados miembros
y también para hacer un reparto de
tareas que tenga sentido en el país uno
de los programas es euro clima plus en
colombia este financia por ejemplo un
componente para proteger los bosques del
choco
en nuestras comunidades han sido
saqueadas en el tema de los recursos
naturales en este caso el tema de d
de los bosques de la idea con este
proyecto es tratar de fortalecer es
fortalecer el tema de gobernanza y que
nuestras comunidades puedan aprovechar
el bosque de una manera sostenible así
llegamos al final de este programa
recuerden que pueden ver más información
ambiental en france24 punto com
[Música]